sublimer ces ruines se fondre dans leur
histoire pour raconter le temps d'un
weekend une architecture pensée avec
l'éruption de 1902
le but était de d'interpréter pour eux
comment l'éruption crée de nouvelles
choses comment l'éruption entraîne à une
nouvelle vie finalement voilà donc
beaucoup d'équipes en fait on
travaillait autour de la Renaissance on
travaille on fait des pas en cours donc
comment on va de finalement de la mort
quelque part à la vie comme on la ville
peut se reconstruire comment il voit la
ville plus tard ces équipes
d'architectes sélectionnées les
candidatures sont arrivées du monde
entier comme c'est de professionnels
devant couverts au Canada
ça faisait plusieurs jours que ce
concours était sur plein de sites
d'architecture j'ai saisi l'opportunité
de candidater à ce festival machocane et
devenir sur cette île pour bâtir une
installation qui avec peu de chance
séduira les gens pour des constructions
futures
qui se destinent d'ailleurs à une
carrière d'architecte lorsque nous
sommes devant les ordinateurs lorsque
nous travaillons lorsque nous faisons
des esquisses etc c'est différent que
des tio le terrain de devoir transporter
des choses ou comment ça se passe voir
quelle matériaux nous avons besoin selon
les types de besoins du coup grâce à
cela on peut partager le patrimoine à
d'autres personnes c'est de l'expérience
effectivement donc quand on voit les
ruines justement de ça leur avait
Coralie on va et les moulures c'est fort
l'architecture est incontestablement un
art elle suggère Zoé et son collègue
vont tailler tous les aspects pour leur
œuvre histoire modernité environnement
et créer en bambou leurs oiseaux du
paradis
ça vient de c'est le nom scientifique de
l'oiseau de paradis en fait le thème de
ce festival c'était l'éruption et nous
on s'intéressait à ce qui se passe après
une éruption volcanique et en fait la
terre elle est fertile donc on s'est
intéressé à la vie après
l'éruption et donc les plantes qui
poussent et l'oiseau de paradis ça nous
paraissait une plante intéressante à
utiliser pour la forme dynamique qu'elle
a
machucam ne bâtit pas seulement des
structures il crée aussi du lien de la
fierté et de la solidarité comme avec
Monsieur maboulot il offre gratuitement
son électricité à ces jeunes architectes
très travailleurs
les prisons sont pleines les hôpitaux
psychiatiques sont prêts partout et
plein même des docteurs on n'a pas les
gens sont pas encouragés à rester ici
nos jeunes s'en vont nos jeunes s'en
vont ailleurs ils ne veulent pas revenir
quand j'ai vu qu'il travaille 12 €
international innovant et atypique qui
le temps d'un week-end fera de saint
Pierre ville de ruines la capitale de
l'architecture